I don't give up my father was drafted in
the Vietnam at 17 and I never seen him
give up so I wanted to be like my father
I got that for my dad this ethic work
ethic I always work hard now I gotta
work harder you in a coma for ten days
you knocking on the door I could have
been a a passing conversation to y'all I
could have been somebody at y'all once
knew need motivation watch a top-10
believe nation
what's that belief nation its heaven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent add something and I want you to
find it embrace it and make a difference
using it so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew in today's lessons from
a man who went from being the child of a
heroin addict and being bullied as a kid
to becoming a successful actor and
comedian he's Tracy Morgan and here's my
take on his top ten rules a success
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one don't take yourself too
seriously listen if you don't laugh
you're gonna cry yeah I can laugh at
myself yeah so I don't see why sometimes
people take themselves so serious
I remember anymore if you're telling me
that never take life too serious you
would never get out alive yeah you need
people like me on the planet to make us
laugh if not would be a wall of time so
we have to take time out sometime to
just laugh at ourselves rule number two
focus on your strengths how does being
on 30 rock compared to being on Saturday
Night Live Saturday Night Live is the
hardest thing I've ever did in my career
period if you could survive Saturday
Night Live then you good as far as shows
show business is concerned and that was
the hardest schedule my ex-wife she was
considered a widow because I was never
home and did you write a lot of your own
stuff I'm Caroline
absolutely not I couldn't deal with the
rejection my first season on Saturday
Night Live almost gets shut down I say
you know what I'm just gonna perform I
put all my strip into performance I'm
gonna let the writers cast me it said
whatever they're gonna cast me in and
when I get fired my little time to shine
I'm gonna blow up the spot and that's
what I did rule number three my personal
favorite never give up actor comedian
Tracy Morgan is in critical condition
after a deadly car crash on the New
Jersey Turnpike over the weekend
Morgan's publicist says the former 30
rock star is responsive following Sunday
surgery at Robert Wood Johnson
University Hospital in New Brunswick New
Jersey where he's been treated for
broken ribs a broken nose and leg around
1:00 a.m. Saturday Morgan was riding in
a limo van after performing at a casino
in Delaware State Police say Morgan's
vehicle was struck from behind by a
Walmart tractor-trailer that failed to
observe slow-moving traffic the impact
flipped Morgan's vehicle on its
I'd killing one person and injuring
several others well when you have a
traumatic brain damages you can see the
scars on my head at that moment but it
first happened when I didn't see any
hope and I couldn't walk before they
taught me how to stand up and sit down
again you don't feel that way but as the
months and the months and the months
went by part of my therapy was seen TV
and seeing my friends and saying if I'm
coming back one day and my wife my wife
my wife made sure that her and my
therapist I wanted to walk my wife it
wasn't it was bigger than TV for me at
that moment I wanted to walk my wife
down the aisle but no cane I want to ask
you how proud you are of what you've
been able to accomplish because it
obviously it hasn't been easy you've had
to put a great deal of effort in there
and was there ever a time when you
almost gave up to saying to yourself
maybe I can't do this well my wife
wouldn't let me do that my son would let
me do that and I looked at my little
daughter's face they wouldn't let me do
that I just hope my tragedy and Jimmy's
death isn't in vain I just hope that the
thing that happened to me can be
prevented now from people just dying on
the road and so I just that's what I
hope and do you feel you're the same but
I'm not a god own give up my father was
drafted in the Vietnam at 17 and I never
see him give up so I wanted to be like
my father even when he had AIDS he never
gave up so we don't do that as Morgan's
rule number four work hard I mean coming
out of that whole tragedy and you know
respect all the families the people that
got that was lost in everything but
coming out of that my car's just second
act as as a perform like how I mean like
how do you feel like what you're gonna
do with this this this stage of your
life this chair I'm not gonna I tell you
one thing Jay I'm not gonna never take
it for granted
I'm gonna work hard every time I'm on
stage even harder I would
I've always worked hard I've always I
got that for my dad this ethic work
ethic I always work hard now I gotta
work harder and not just on stage but
that show that love or stage real number
5 see things differently crazy the way
you break their own things and your
comedy is for life to me is your thinker
I just think that I have a perspective
and I like I see things the way I see
them and I think that they're different
than everyone else I think everyone has
a unique perspective but we get so
caught up in you know watching TV that
we go whatever way we see you know
whatever culture we see you know so but
I just like this my father told me that
man I see things the way I see them that
third eye is open the genies out of the
bottle and he's not going back in go
back where seriously I got like my
mid-morning ones I got to tell life I
got to talk to where I see it rule
number six go through the struggles why
did you decide to write a memoir now why
did I decide to write a memoir now
because they gave me a big bag of money
now how long did it take you to write
the book about two years there was a lot
of old wounds reopened it was a lot of
me going back to my father and my mother
and what we had to go through living and
growing up in the projects
and my childhood of running away in all
my friends that are lost to the to the
war to the struggle to statistics it was
all of that so two years took me a long
time to write it man hmm I took my time
with it and at the time I was going to
divorce with my wife it's just a lot of
stuff happening in my life man the duis
all of that stuff was going on so you
did go through a fairly rough time a
couple of years ago I mean no more than
anybody in this room you know without no
struggle there is no progress mm-hmm
what sort of pulled you out of it
belief my belief in God I'm holding on
to him staying funny do all of that
stuff stamp funny you know follows my
monsters in you mom dead I'm going rule
number seven tell the truth I was funny
it's funny
PC has no place in comedy don't
the truth does but you probably know why
we love him because he was always honest
with us
no matter how tragic it was yeah the
changes tell you he did coke he told you
where he bought it from he told you if
it was good or not and I'm gonna say one
of the gram but that's why I get it from
the Great's how many guards delusive
balls you can't go like a Ralph Kramden
you can't go bang zoom me your wife on
TV now that's domestic violence yeah but
we take everything now and PC and PC has
taught us to lie it's telling Tommen is
his breath stink you and a hack some do
we want some gone that's what it is the
truth is the truth we all laugh at the
truth you know why you just laughed
cause it's true is prep to sting yeah
man am I gonna say that his prep to
sting that's what I love Muslims that's
what I love about children you tell the
truth
yeah and I have that inquisitive mind
like a child I don't know no better
I'm sorry if I hurt you I don't know the
truth rule number eight appreciate life
how are back to work are you are you
easing your way in or you what we saw
you already nothing man you're back so
hard no chance I'm going home and I get
on stage my approach it to say well Pro
sit my whole life with nothing to lose
me I approach it I'm letting it all hang
out let it all hang out well you find
you have a balance though right now
because I know you've been through so
much I tapped into something that nobody
else could tap into I would turn other
side I came back you in a coma for ten
days you knocking on the door
I guess my room wasn't ready yeah he's
still got things I'm not ready for you
son not this amazing man thank watching
you glow man the clarity like I've know
you so feel that way a chance so many
faces when we be here with cha yeah you
know
cuz this I could have been of a passing
conversation to y'all I could have been
somebody out y'all once knew and now I'm
here so I appreciate life let me tell
you something young blood do that put
that phone away man cuz when I'm saying
is real I don't think you can happen to
me I love you wrote up wrote out me got
live every day all day rule number nine
be fearless on 30 rock they did take as
it sounds like they take just about
everything and made a plot you can make
fun of stuff like people were wondering
now people are sensitive can we make fun
of Michael Jackson and Lyla I've been on
a road I've heard media is starting to
make fun of it cuz you have to move on
you know grieve a few months but I put
it into sorrow
you know Michael Jackson wouldn't want
us to sit around feeling sorry for them
now people ask me all the time do you
think we should make fun or Obama why
not did you see his haircut I'm starting
from the top this might need to do Sasha
here hello Bernie are here Doug and
Michelle knows we are as some going on
back in the days and rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is have fun when I came out to
coma my whole family came to us a little
visit me just to tell me they love me a
whole height my whole family came just
to tell me they loved me
except for my grandmother like every
other old black woman no she care about
his education I my grandma I made it I
survived she said good now you go back
get your GED
do someone chill down stuff we got
second chance I said go grandma I was on
30 rock she said if you had your GED you
been on 60
[Music]
now I've got a really special Tracy
Morgan bonus clip on how to keep it real
but before that I want to know what did
you learn from this video what was the
most important lesson you're going to
apply somehow to your life or your
business leave it down in the comments
below I want to see what you have to say
and when you write it down it's much
more likely that you're actually gonna
take action on it which is the most
important thing put it in the comments
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
and enjoy the bonus clip
Tracy I know that you got material that
you go to but I'm pretty sure just
sitting down with you every night got to
be different though it is because you
can go in a direction man I remember man
one time you came to the neighborhood
and we say this steel you had gotten to
like the government spicy ham and we
still coming Gees but the spicy ham with
it yeah man is real stuff man I like to
do stuff on stage that everybody can
relate and identify with and that's
called the truth yeah man don't laugh at
lies yes sir giggling but lies earth but
the truth is something everybody can
relate the most important work ever if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be to like a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]